Der Bauch kommt dahin,
wir kleben ihn einfach an.
Dann passen wir
noch die Farbe an.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen
Angst,wenn ich das mache.
Ich habe Angst, dass
ich dann schwanger werde.
Davor hab ich Angst, und
ich möchte Esther (ihre Mutter)
verschonen damit.
Und was sagst du zum
Thema Sexualität?
Dazu sage ich selber
nicht viel.
Für die meisten
Menschen wird es ...
... bei diesem Thema
eher ungemütlich.
Genau!
Julia, du hast ja ein Hormon-
Pflaster, das verhütet.
Ja, genau. Und das hilft, also
verhindert eine Schwangerschaft.
Ich finde es schön und toll ...
... aber irgendwann... also...
ich sag das Wort jetzt nicht.
Sonst flippt Eshter aus.
Wenn Julia schwanger würde,
wäre das wie bei jeder Frau.
Es wäre ihre Entscheidung, ob
sie das Kind bekommen will ...
... oder nicht. Laut Menschen-
Recht, hat jeder Mensch das ...
... Recht ein Kind zu bekommen.
Wir müssten eine Institution ...
... suchen, die bereit wäre,auch
den Säugling mitzutragen.
Remo und Julia wären nicht in
der Lage, den Säugling ...
... während 24 Stunden am
Tag zu betreuen.
Ein Kind bekommen, darf sie.
Und abtreiben darf sie auch.
Aber verhindern, dass sie
schwanger wird, ...
... ist mit Einschränkungen
ihrer Rechte, also der ...
... Menschenrechte
verbunden.
Das ist dumm und nicht
nachzuvollziehen.
Denn wenn Julias Kind ohne
Down-Syndrom zur Welt ...
... käme, so wären Julia
und Remo als Eltern ...
... hofffnungslos überfordert.
Bist du auch schwanger?
Nein! Und das möchte
ich auch nicht.
Ich will nur spielen, dass
ich schwanger wäre.
Das ist jetzt der Bauch.
Den passen wir noch
deiner Hautfarbe an.
Bis wir den Bauch fixiert
haben, kannst du den BH ...
... anbehalten.
Ahh, Dankeschön!!
Julia, ist es ok für dich, wenn
ich dir den BH jetzt hochziehe?
Ja du darfst.
Wir schützen dich
mit einem Tuch.
Kannst du den kleinen
Finger noch so halten?
Ja, so ist es perfekt!
Julia, schau mal da
hinauf. Genau, super!
Ich streiche dir noch die
Haare ein bisschen aus
dem Gesicht.
Schau mit viel Würde und
Edelkeit. Wie eine Ritterin.
Zum Spielen ist schwanger
sein ok. Aber nicht in echt!
Uih  nein. Dann hast du
keine Freizeit mehr ...
... kannst nicht mehr
iPad schauen ...
... ich könnte nicht mehr
malen, einfach nichts mehr
machen.
Ich wäre 24 Stunden nur
noch mit dem Baby ...
... und das ist so anstrengend!
Nein, das mach ich nicht!
Ich hätte die Möglichkeit
gehabt, Julia abzutreiben.
Aber ich bin froh,
dass Julia lebt!